in addition to spreading more quickly
it also now appears that there is some
evidence that the new variant the
variant that was first identified in
london and the south east may be
associated with a higher degree of
mortality boris johnson's warning that
the new
covid variant may be 30 percent more
deadly than the original strain
coinciding with an emotive new tv
advertising campaign
has raised fears that england's lockdown
could go on for longer
but top scientists have questioned the
prime minister's warning
claiming it's too early to draw strong
conclusions
about increased mortality rates my first
reaction was that it was possibly a
little bit presumptuous to do that when
the data were in their very early stages
if you're polling for elections you need
to sample a certain proportion of people
to have a good idea of which way an
election is going to go and it's the
same with these data if we only have a
very small sample
it may be that actually you're not
reflecting what's truly going on
speaking alongside the pm when he made
his 30
claim his own chief scientific adviser
sir patrick valance
also admitted there was a lot of
uncertainty around the numbers
as well as warning about the new variant
being more lethal
the prime minister has also signaled
that to stop
dangerous new variants entering the uk
more curbs on international travel are
likely
after images of crowded arrivals halls
at uk airports this weekend
tory mps accept that some further
restrictions
are necessary i think it wouldn't be
unwise for us to look very hard at our
borders
and to really consider whether or not
now is the time
to make sure that we control access and
therefore restrain
any spread i think that's an important
thing to look at we need to
analyze the cost and make sure that what
it is actually doing is protecting us
and not just making it harder for those
who need to see family
it's likely that ministers will back the
introduction of covid hotels
with airport hotels being used to
quarantine international arrivals
a scheme already in use in australia and
new zealand
the travel industry is deeply hostile to
the idea however
if the government put in place hotel
quarantine for everybody coming into the
uk
it would snuff out recovery in the
aviation and travel sector
it would reduce confidence it would mean
people wouldn't be prepared to book
future holidays
until they could be certain that they
wouldn't have to quarantine
when they returned to the uk it would be
a hugely damaging
policy measure and for that reason i
think the government needs to think
very very carefully before they do
something that deliberately
hurts the economy the prime minister has
hailed the success of the vaccine
program so far
but the government's big fear is that
vaccines may be less effective
against another new variant john craig
sky news